you are supposed to protect your wife
how is it protecting your wife when you
are letting her sleep with another guy
it's officially been a week since I let
my wife do porn with another guy I felt
a little jealous at first but overall it
wasn't that big of a deal she's watched
me sleep with hundreds of girls and it's
never affected our relationship
sleeping with that gentleman has been oh
amazing for both her career and our
business plug talk show overall I'm glad
we did it and I'm happy to report her
vagina has returned to its original
pre-vbc size do you see what
trouble we get into when we assume that
men and women are equal this is what we
get